[Music]
do you know how many choices you make in
a typical day
a typical week
i recently did a survey with over 2 000
americans
and the average number of choices that
the typical american reports making is
about 70 in a typical day
it was also recently a a study done with
ceos in which they followed ceos around
for a whole week
and these scientists simply documented
all the various tasks that these ceos
engaged in and how much time they spent
engaging in making decisions related to
these tasks
and they found that the average ceo
engaged in about 139 tasks in a week
each task was made up of many many many
many sub choices of course fifty percent
of their decisions were made in nine
minutes or less
only about twelve percent of the
decisions did they make an hour or more
of their time
think about your own choices
do you know how many choices make it
into your nine minute category versus
your one hour category
how well do you think you're doing it
managing those choices
today i want to talk about one of the
biggest modern day choosing problems
that we have which is the choice
overload problem
i want to talk about the problem and
some potential solutions
now as i talk about this problem i'm
going to have some questions for you and
i'm going to want to know your answers
so when i ask you a question since i'm
blind
only raise your hands if you want to
burn off some calories
otherwise when i ask you a question and
if your answer is yes i'd like you to
clap your hands
so for my first question for you today
are you guys ready to hear about the
choice overload problem
thank you
so when i was a graduate student at
stanford university i used to go to this
very very upscale grocery store at least
at that time it was truly upscale it was
a store called draeger's
now this store it was almost like going
to an amusement park they had 250
different kinds of mustards and vinegars
and over 500 different kinds of fruits
and vegetables and more than two dozen
different kinds of bottled water and
this is during a time when we actually
used to drink tap water
i used to love going to this store
but
on one occasion i asked myself well how
come you never buy anything oh here's
their olive oil aisle they had over 75
different kinds of olive oils including
those that were in a locked case that
came from a thousand-year-old olive
trees
so i one day i decided to pay a visit to
the manager and i asked the manager
you know is this model of offering
people all this choice really working
and he pointed to the bus loads of
tourists that would show up every day
with cameras ready usually
we decided to do a little experiment
and we picked jam for our experiment
here's their jam aisle they had 348
different kinds of jam we set up a
little tasting booth right near the
entrance of the store we either put out
six different flavors of jam or 24
different flavors of jam and we looked
at two things
first
in which case were people more likely to
you know stop sample some jam
more people stopped when they were 24
about 60 percent
than when there were six about 40
percent
the next thing we looked at is in which
case were people more likely to buy a
jar of jam and now we see the opposite
effect of the people who stopped when
they were 24 only three percent of them
actually bought a jar of jam of the
people who stopped when they were six
well now we saw that 30 percent of them
actually bought a jar of jam now if you
do the math people were at least six
times more likely to buy a jar of jam if
they encountered six than if they
encountered 24. now choosing not to buy
a jar of jam is actually probably good
for us at least it's good for our
waistlines but it turns out that this
choice overload problem affects us even
in very consequential decisions we
choose not to choose even when it goes
against our best self-interests
so now for the topic of today financial
savings
this is a study that i did with guru i'm
now going to describe to you a study i
did with guru huberman amir kaminika
weijiang where we looked at the
retirement savings decisions
of nearly a million americans
from about 650 plants
all in the u.s
and what we looked at was whether the
number of fund offerings available in a
retirement savings plan the 401k plan
does that affect people's likelihood to
save more for tomorrow
and what we found was that indeed there
was a correlation so in these plans we
had about 657 plans that ranged from
offering people anywhere from two to
fifty nine different fund offerings
and what we found was that the more
funds offered indeed there was
less participation rates so if you look
at the extremes those plans that offered
you two funds participation rates were
around in the mid 70s still not as high
as we want it to be
in those plans that offered nearly 60
funds participation rates have now
dropped to about 60
percentile
now it turns out that even if you do
choose to participate
when there are more choices present
even then it has negative consequences
so for those people who did choose to
participate the more choices available
the more likely people were to
completely avoid stocks or equity funds
the more choices available the more
likely they were to put all their money
in pure money market accounts now
neither of these extreme decisions are
the kinds of decisions that any of us
would recommend for people when you're
considering their future financial
well-being
well over the past decade we have
observed three main negative
consequences to offering people more and
more choices
they're more likely to delay choosing
procrastinate even when it goes against
their best self-interest they're more
likely to make worse choices worse
financial choices medical choices
they're more likely to choose things
that make them less satisfied even when
they do objectively better
the main reason for this
is because well we might enjoy gazing at
those giant walls of mayonnaises
mustards vinegars jams but we can't
actually do the math of comparing and
contrasting and actually picking from
that stunning display
so what i want to propose to you today
are four simple techniques
techniques that we have tested in one
way or another in different race
research venues that you can easily
apply in your businesses
the first
cut
you've heard it said before but it's
never been more true than today that
less is more
people are always upset when i say cut
they're always worried they're going to
lose shelf space but in fact what we're
seeing more and more is that the if you
are willing to cut get rid of those
extraneous redundant options well
there's an increase in sales
there's a lowering of costs there's an
improvement of the choosing experience
when procter and gamble went from 26
different kinds of head and shoulders to
15 they saw an increase in sales by 10
when the golden cat corporation got rid
of their 10 worst selling cat litter
products they saw an increase in profits
by 87 percent
a function of both increase in sales and
lowering of costs
you know the average grocery store today
offers you 45 000 products the typical
walmart today offers you a hundred
thousand products but the ninth
the ninth largest retailer the ninth
biggest retailer in the world today is
aldi's and it offers you only fourteen
1400 products one kind of canned tomato
sauce
now in the financial savings world i
think one of the best examples that has
recently come out on how to best manage
the choice offerings has actually been
something that david labson was heavily
involved in designing which is the
program that they have at harvard
every single harvard employee is now
automatically enrolled in the lifecycle
fund for those people who actually want
to choose
they're given 20 funds not 300 or more
funds you know often people say i don't
know how to cut
they're all important choices and the
first thing i do is i ask the employees
tell me how these choices are different
from one another and if your employees
can't tell them apart neither can your
consumers
now
before we started our session this
afternoon i had a chat with gary
and gary said that he would be willing
to offer people in this audience and all
expenses paid free vacation to the most
beautiful road in the world
here's a description of the road
okay and i'd like you to read it and now
i'll give you a few seconds to read it
and then i want you to clap your hands
if you're ready to take gary up on his
offer
okay
anybody who's ready to take him up on
his offer
is that all
all right let me show you some more
about this
you guys knew there was a trick didn't
you
now who's ready to go on this trip
i think i might have actually heard more
hands
[Laughter]
all right
now
in fact you had objectively more
information the first time around than
the second time around but i would
venture to guess that you felt that it
was more real the second time around
because the pictures made it feel more
real to you
which brings me to the second technique
for handling the choice overload problem
which is concretization
that in order for people to understand
the differences between the choices they
have to be able to understand the
consequences associated with each choice
and that the consequences need to be
felt
in a vivid sort of way in a very
concrete way
why do people spend an average of
fifteen to thirty percent more when they
use an atm card or a credit card as
opposed to cash because it doesn't feel
like real money
and it turns out that making it feel
more concrete can actually be a very
positive tool to use in getting people
to save more so a study that i did with
shlomi bernardi and alessandro privatero
we looked at
we did a study with people at ing
employees that are all working at ing
and now these people were all in a
session where they're doing enrollment
for their 401k plan and during that
session we kept the session exactly the
way it used to be but we added one
little thing
the one little thing we added
was we asked people to just think about
all the positive things that would
happen in your life if you saved more
by doing that simple thing
there was an increase in enrollment by
and there was an increase in the amount
of people that were willing to save in
terms of the amount that they were
willing to put down into their savings
account by 4
the third technique categorization
you know we can handle more categories
than we can handle choices
so for example
here's a study we did in a magazine
aisle turns out that in wegmans grocery
stores up and down the northeast
corridor the magazine aisles range
anywhere from 331 different kinds of
magazines versus all the way up to 664.
but you know what
if i show you 600 magazines and i divide
them up into 10 categories versus i show
you 400 magazines and divide them up
into 20 categories
you believe that i have given you more
choice and a better choosing experience
if i gave you the 400 than if i gave you
the 600
because the categories tell me how to
tell them apart
here are two different jewelry displays
one is called jazz the other one is
called swing
if you think the display on the left is
swing and the display on the right is
jazz clap your hands
okay there's some
if you think the one on the left is jazz
and the one on the right is swing clap
your hands
okay a bit more
okay now it turns out you're right the
one on the left is jazz and the one on
the right is swing but you know what
this is a highly
useless categorization scheme
you know the categories need to say
something to the chooser not the choice
maker and you often see that problem
when it comes down to that those long
lists of all these funds who are they
actually supposed to be informing
my fourth technique condition for
complexity
it turns out we can actually handle a
lot more information than we think we
can we just got to take it a little
easier we have got to gradually increase
the complexity i'm going to show you one
example of what i'm talking about let's
take a very very complicated decision
buying a car
here's a german car manufacturer that
gives you the opportunity to completely
custom make your car you're going to
make 60 different decisions completely
make up your car now these decisions
vary in the number of choices that they
offer per decision
car colors exterior car colors i've got
56 choices
engine gear shift four choices
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to vary the order in which these
decisions appear so half of the
customers are going to go from high
choice 56 car colors to low choice four
gear shifts the other half of the
customers are going to go from low
choice four gear shifts to 56 car
collars high choice
what am i going to look at
how engaged you are if you keep hitting
the default button per decision that
means you're getting overwhelmed that
means i'm losing you
what you find is the people that go from
high choice to low choice they're
hitting that default button over and
over and over again we're losing them
they go from low choice to high choice
they're hanging in there it's the same
information
it's the same number of choices the only
thing that i have done is i have varied
the order in which that information is
presented if i start you off easy i
learn how to choose
even though
choosing gearshift doesn't tell me
anything about my preferences for
interior decor
it still prepares me for how to choose
it also gets me excited about this big
product that i'm putting together so i'm
more willing to be motivated to be
engaged
so let me recap
i have talked about four techniques for
mitigating the problem of choice
overload
cut get rid of the extraneous
alternatives concretize make it real
categorize we can handle more categories
less choices
condition for complexity
all of these techniques that i'm
describing to you today are designed to
help you manage your choices better for
you you can use them on yourself better
for the people that you are serving
because i believe that the key
to getting the most from choice is to be
choosy about choosing and the more we're
able to be choosy about choosing the
better we will be able to practice the
art of choosing thank you very much